simone veil bonjour je vous présente
florence belkacem qui va faire du beau
avec moi est ce que vous connaissez les
amis
je bouge je les connais par la
télévision claire nebout cécilia ma
biche harper y est déjà et francis
lalanne que vous avez vu ramatuelle en
s'allumant est-ce que devant vous on
peut allumer une cigarette
on a mis ça arrive souvent ça arrive sur
ça arrive souvent et je ne suis pas du
tout une terroriste en la matière ce que
je crois c'est qu'aujourd'hui il ya tout
de même une campagne contre le tabagisme
et où les médecins ont justement
augmenté on évite de fumer à la
télévision alors c'est pas moins de sa
gêne mais c'est je dirais dans le cadre
de cette action pédagogique que je crois
qu'on peut faire un effort je vais faire
un effort jusqu'à la fin de cette
interview je ne fais moi m non je crois
que ça donne vraiment c'est une des
choses sur lesquelles les médecins
insistent le plus c'est l'image qui est
donnée
à la télévision justement par des gens
comme vous
célèbre qui sont les idoles des jeunes
souvent et bien le fait
le fait de fumer
certaines images qui est en réalité très
positif pour le tabac et donc une
incitation vous avez commandé à périers
alors ça voudrait pas d'exemple
d'alcoolisme ou non on n'est pas
alcoolique parce que parce que l'on voit
une coupe de champagne sa manche et de
soif pendant bref faire alors je préfère
boire un verre d'eau mais mes jeux saba
il ya vraiment une pression au deuxième
tour
monsieur bart pour être élu est obligé
de prendre les voix de le pen est ce que
vous lui demanderez de prendre une
position publique
je crois que même dès le premier tour il
est tout à fait souhaitable que toutes
les personnalités candidat aux élections
présidentielles se situe très clairement
par rapport aux idées de monsieur le pen
et par rapport à ce que représente le
front national cela dit qu'est ce que ça
veut dire prendre deuxième tour les voix
de monsieur le pen quand vous votez les
bulletins de vote ne porte pas un petit
signe qui montre que ce sont des voix
qui viennent de tel ou tel de tel ou tel
type des lecteurs d'abord je suis
convaincu qu'au premier tour
il ya des gens qui voteront
aux extrêmes je dirais aussi bien
d'ailleurs pour madame la guinée par une
espèce de vote de refus ce qui
d'ailleurs est en soi déjà à une façon
de manifester et je trouve toujours
préoccupant qu'il y ait des gens qui
choisissent les extrêmes par votre refus
des candidats jeu placé au deuxième vote
rendement risque d'être élue avec les
voix de pas mais vous ne saurez pas vous
ne serez pas on sait très bien
qu'aujourd'hui
il y a une grande partie des électeurs
de monsieur le pen qui viennent qui
vient du parti communiste ou même du
parti socialiste et de la gauche toutes
les études qui ont été faites dans l'est
toutes les études qui ont été faites
dans certaines villes où il ya eu un
fort pourcentage de
voir sur
les candidats de monsieur domaine sont
des quartiers où il y avait des voix de
gauche très important donc on peux
absolument pas dire il ya tel
pourcentage ou telle voie viennent jouer
les monsieur le vent et les gens mais
disque est très important revanche cessé
de se démarquer très clairement ce que
le match est prise
excusez moi comme tous les
les gens comme tous les hommes
politiques de la droite libérale des
ondes qui disent nous on fait bien la
différence entre le pen et les électeurs
devant moi je dis pas je fais la
différence entre les électeurs et
monsieur absolument pas c'est pas du
tout le discours j'ai que je tiens je
vous dis simplement qu'on ne peut pas
savoir je dis je dis d'abord c'est vrai
qu'un certain nombre d électeurs non
plus partagent pas tous les
les sentiments et les idées de monsieur
le pen s'était bien qu'à une grande
partie de rejet et donc il faut bien
voir les raisons de ce rejet ce que je
dis simplement c'est une pousse tard si
vous voulez matériel qui fait qu'au
moment où les gens votent
on ne sait pas quelle est l'autorité
pour raymond barre ça devient des bombes
papa baril depuis six mois mais les bons
libéraux mais c'est pas que ça devient
des banlieues on sait que ceux qui
n'avaient pas les moyens
vous l'avez pas de moyen de savoir si
ces 5% 10%
ça sera bien des lecteurs en général
très souvent pour leur santé vos
premiers au sommet
on a tenté une expérience hier c'était
la fête le blanc rouge justement parce
que cette question nous importe c'est à
dire que 1 électeurs de le pen au
premier tour devient
l'électeur libéral au deuxième et on a
demandé à notre ami philippe guérin ici
présent une allée hier la fête du front
national a fait le blanc rouge pour
demander aux militants du front pour
combattre et non ce qu'ils pensaient de
vous ce qu'il pensait des gens on va
regarder de sujet on va regarder le
sujet je n'aime pas du tout simone veil
simone veil aujourd'hui fait beaucoup de
flamme de deux plats deux
site agréé au secours en ce qui concerne
ce que tu es ce qu'a dit monsieur le pen
et simone veil oublie simplement qu'elle
est responsable de la loi sur
l'avortement que ce sont des milliers
d'enfants de bébé que l'on tue dans le
saint lormel juteau ça ignoble siro
front national n'a pas sa place ici
seulement démocratie simone veil a droit
à la parole comme jean marie le pen
je n'aime pas du tout madame simone veil
je lui reproche en particulier sa loi
sur l'avortement
qui entraînait génocide de centaines de
milliers voire de millions de jeunes
français de deux petits français et de
futurs qui ne se réaliseront jamais une
femme de gauche d'une fan de huy de
gauche éventuellement et puis bon à la
passe et facile à dire qu'il n'a rien à
voir avec les y voilà
il n'a rien à voir avec simone veil bon
ben je peux pas trop dire parce que je
la connais pas assez mince
bon vous me poserez la question sur
n'importe qui je vous dirai non
c'est toujours pareil il y en a qu'un
c'est le pen
simone veil pour moi c'est vraiment
enfin je dirais c'est l'objection
politique c'est vraiment je bondis
j'aurai je crois que j'aurais pas de
termes pour décrire une femme je pense
qu'il y a
qui a été d'un cynisme qui prend des
airs de vierge offensée
quand elle parle du front national et de
tout ce qui pourrait faire le front
national c'est le diable je pense quand
même qu'il faudrait que elles
réfléchissent un petit peu sur tout ce
qu'elle fait sur les millions de morts
qu'elle as déjà sur la conscience qu'est
ce que vous pensez de simone veil
beaucoup de mal c'est une femme
dangereuse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette surprise pas du tout il va falloir
vous soyez très exigeante avec monsieur
bart je ne suis pas du tout surpris je
reçois du courrier de ce genre
fréquemment et donc ça ne va pas
absolument rien si vous montrer mon
courrier il est quelques fois pire que
ça je me sais pas ce que vous disiez
mais là je me lasse si vous voulez ce
n'est pas que je
je des douanes cet électorat pas du tout
c'est pas du tout que je trouve que
c'est pas parce qu'il m'attaque mais
c'est simplement sur leur idée quand je
pense tout de même qu'on a un petit peu
trier là c'est pas vraiment nous aider
ces deux
dans son micro il y avait des choses
beaucoup plus saignant mai
l'info devant la caméra c'est resté
exactement comme non mais très bien ça
veut dire c'est que je crois tout de
même qu'à une part dans les oreilles
dans son exigeante avec monsieur bah moi
je n'en vois qu'une supposition confirme
que c'est il apprécie vraiment vous vous
parlez toujours de monsieur monsieur 150
gbagbo soutenu mais écoutez pour
l'instant je ne soutiens aucun candidat
parce qu'il n'est pas candidat
j'essaie d'abord dit non je n'ai pas
déclaré de ça alors je suis tout à fait
désolé puisque vous revenez là dessus
avec une espèce de certitudes j'ai
simplement dit que je suis du df
personne n'ignore je ne cache pas et que
je pensais il ya encore des ventes à ça
et que je trouvais qu'il fallait que
l'udf est un candidat aux élections
présidentielles parce qu'une grande
formation politique dans un système
constitutionnel n'existe pas si elle n'a
pas un candidat aux élections
présidentielles c'est vrai que je trouve
qu'il ya trop d'ambiguïtés
je relisais
les commentaires qui ont été faits par
une grande partie de la classe politique
au lendemain des déclarations j'avais
fait sur dreux eh bien c'était très peu
claires mais je crois que maintenant il
est vraiment temps des effets de la
préfecture oui non seulement la primaire
mais vous allez vous dire que j'ai été
scellée dans la rue les deux personnes
pratiquement ne m'a ne m'a soutenu et
que les propos tenus ont été même dans
la majorité modérée extrêmement dur à
mon endroit et que le courrier que j'ai
reçu je parlais du courrier le noir est
toujours très intéressant le courrier
que j'ai reçue était aussi
étaient aussi présents alors je me
réjouis de voir que maintenant tout de
même beaucoup ont pris position de façon
beaucoup plus clair mais c'est vrai vous
avez raison c'est vrai qu'il y en a qui
sont gênés par les déclarations
c'est michel mois capoue verger malhuret
qu'on peut faire d'autre
et je crois que on ne peut plus
maintenant c'est ça me plaît et
d'ailleurs je crois que surtout la
classe politique devrait comprendre
qu'elle a tout à y gagner
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars dit tu es abonné vous mettez un
pouce bleus